descending to the deep the ocean
twilight zone where daylight barely
penetrates yet life still thrives Sky
News joined marine scientists from the
nekton mission in Bermuda three years
ago now we're rejoining the team for a
new voyage to explore Aldabra a remote
coral atoll in the Seychelles and
broadcasting the first ever live TV news
bulletins from under the water to draw
attention to the plight of the world's
oceans plastic pollution climate change
and overfishing threaten coral reefs the
most diverse ecosystem on the planet
this mission will push the boundaries of
both science and broadcasting the
satellite dishes are now here but the
mothership still needs to be cabled up
and rigged with cameras and still to
come the two mini submarines that will
take us and you down into the deep for
three live one-hour programs the scale
of this is quite extraordinary the
oceans affair is being refitted in
Bremerhaven on Germany's North Sea coast
once in the Seychelles researchers will
dive up to 300 metres below the surface
surveying deep water reefs that no one
has been to before they expect to find
hundreds if not thousands of new species
I think we've been looking up when we
should have been looking down I mean
we've had this great era of space
exploration and that has pushed back the
frontiers of our knowledge but the deep
ocean is the last great frontier it's
the last major piece of our planet we
still don't know about coral reefs
Harbor a quarter of all marine species
but climate change is warming the Seas
and on current trends 99% of shallow
water coral will die the Indian Ocean is
one of the least explored areas in the
world
the nekton scientist fear we could be
the last generation to see the reefs in
all their glory this change is happening
very quickly so the last 50 years coral
reefs have experienced changes that they
have an experience for the last
thousands of years so we are really kind
of in a rush to try and understand the
the have kind of baseline information of
coral reefs so we understand how they
will change in the future
for two years sky ocean rescue has
highlighted the scourge of plastic by
taking viewers down into the deep we
hope to inspire global action to save
the coral on which so much marine life
depends Tamas more Sky News Bremerhaven
in Germany